[Musik]
hallo meine Lieben heute morgen bin ich
richtig gestresst aufgewacht ich weiß
nicht es liegt einfach irgendwie so viel
an im Moment und immer wenn das der Fall
ist brauche ich irgendwie sowas
keksartiges Cookies irgendwas wo man
sich denkt geil das gönne ich mir jetzt
und dann bin ich aufgewacht hab mit ham
gequatscht und meinte was hältst du von
Schoko Cookies so richtig American Style
mit cream cheese in drin als Füllung
schon geil ne du wollst ir mit Subway
Cookies machen genau so Subway Style
Cookies ich le gerade direkt los denn
ihr wisst ja bei meinen Videos findet
ihr die ganz genauen Mengenangaben immer
unten in der Infobox in der Infobox ich
nehme mir jetzt hier zuerst mal für die
Füllung die bereiten wir zuerst vor weil
wir das gleich kalt stellen müssen nehme
ich mir doppelrah Frischkäse z.B
Philadelphia also nimmt da keine
fettarme Variante auf jeden Fall
Doppelrahmen sonst wird nämlich so ein
bisschen flüssig und das wollen wir
nicht und da Siebe ich jetzt hier Zucker
rein und ganz wichtig
Vanilleextrakt sonst schmeckt ein
bisschen langweilig und das wollen wir
ja nicht so ein bisschen mehr das Ganze
einmal glatt rühren da könnt ihr euch
entweder ein Schneebesen nehmen oder mit
dem Teigschaber so ein bisschen auch den
Käse geschmeidig rühren der ist ja
anfangs immer ein bisschen fester oder
nimmt den halt früher aus dem
Kühlschrank dann ist es ein bisschen
einfacher und das füllen wir dann in
einen Spritzbeutel und damit spritze ich
dann 20 Häubchen auf mein Backpapier
habe ich einfach so ein Holzbrett unten
drunter und das ist dann später unsere
Füllung das muss aber eingefroren werden
damit wir das schön in den Keks
reinlegen
[Musik]
können die Füllung darf jetzt so 20 25
Minuten in die Tiefkühltruhe wenn ihr da
kein Platz habt ginge auch der
Kühlschrank braucht dann aber doch eine
Stunde macht euch Platz im
Tiefkühlschrank das ist nämlich die
bessere Lösung dann wird nämlich richtig
schön fest und ihr könnt es gut weiter
verarbeiten ich mache jetzt in der
Zwischenzeit den habe ich zwischenzeig
gesagt ich weiß es nicht ich weiß was du
gesagt hast ich meine du hörst mir eh
nie zu h nicht zu du bist immer so du
merkst do nie wenn ich irgendwo Mehl im
Gesicht hängen habe oder mein Oberteil
hat ich auch mal falsch rum in einem
Video wo du gedreht hast hast du auch
nicht gemerktin Oberteil falsch das ist
jetzt richtig das hat der hamser
übrigens gekauft danke dafür übrigens
ich mache in der Zwischenzeit den Teig
dafür nehme ich jetzt zimmerwarme Butter
holt die früh genug aus dem Kühlschrank
am besten so anderthalb Stunden vorher
dann ist es richtig schön zimmerwarm und
da gebe ich den braunen Rohrzucker mit
dazu der macht einfach noch so ein
karamelligen Geschmack ihr könntet auch
weißen Zucker nehmen das wäre eigentlich
auch kein Problem wenn ihr den braunen
jetzt gerade nicht da habt dann kommt
Vanilleextrakt zum
Einsatz V cool muss
überspielen so dann kommt Vanilleextrakt
noch mit rein richtig lecker so und das
ganze wird jetzt ich habe jetzt kein
schneebesenausssetz dran sondern den mit
der Gummilippe der die ränner noch
mitnimmt der wird jetzt so okay die
Maschine ist leistungsstark da reicht do
schon eine Minute aber in der Regel so
zwei zweieinhalb bis D Minuten wird das
ganze richtig schön fluffig und hcremig
[Musik]
gemixt so butterzuckermasse ist richtig
schön fluffig genauso muss sie sein
eigentlich ist es ein simpler Teig und
generelles Rezept hat auch nur wenige
Zutaten und gar nicht so die exotischen
Zutaten überhaupt nicht daher vielleicht
könnt ihr auch direkt loslegen wenn ihr
alles daheim habt dann könnt ihr direkt
anfangen mit dem Backen so Eier gebe ich
jetzt nacheinander dazu es ist besser
wenn sie Zimmertemperatur haben wenn
nicht ist es auch nicht so schlimm aber
so vermischen Sie sich einfach jetzt
besser mit der restlichen Masse und ich
lasse es jetzt langsam einfach
Einarbeiten in den Teig gibt dann das
zweite ein mit dazu und danach kommen
auch schon die trockenen Zutaten mit
hinzu das ist einfach nur mehl und
Backpulver vorab einmal kurz miteinander
verrühren und sieben und dann ist der
Teig
[Musik]
ready oh fast hätte ich eine Zutat
vergessen und zwar den Backkakao ich
denke schon warum ist das noch nicht
dunkel und schokoladig das ist weil ich
gesagt habe ist dchokoladig ne es ist
immer weil du irgendwas gemacht hast ja
ich habe dich daran erinnert jetzt oder
g das ist jetzt aber so richtig ich hole
ganz kurz mein Backkakao und dann sie
ich auch noch hinzu und dann wird
verrührt SEB Stunden spter wir warten K
oh nein wartet jetzt oh mein Gott der
ist anderen Schrank typisch du so ganz
kurz drei Tage später da ist er doch da
ist ich krieg nee das ist mir zu
stressig gerade okay
warte schon ganz schwitzigen Rücken hier
wir haben jetzt übrigens unten und oben
so
so Deckel für unser Sieb verlinke ich e
übrigens in die Infobox genauso wie alle
meine Produkte aber das ist echt cool
weil so kann ich direkt auf die Waage
legen wiege jetzt hier direkt im Sieb ab
ich weiß ja wie viel Gram da reinkommen
und dann habe ich keine Sauerei und muss
keine weitere schüsselreckig machen
so und ein
reie so jetzt sieht no mal ganz anders
aus ne der Farbe viel besser so okay
jetzt hab der ist das Gefühl dass ist
viel zu viel trockene Masse viel zu viel
für die buttereiermasse aber es ist
genau richtig es wird sich dann wirklich
binnen 10 Sekunden miteinander verbinden
und dann ist der Teig
[Musik]
ready gute Laune heute wo wir gestresst
sind gute Laune
komm es gibt Phasen im Leben da da
wächst es über den über ein überm Kopf
Deut hab ich auch verlernt aber es ist
so es ist so und es wird es wird es wird
doch bessere Zeiten geben im Leben ich
weiß was du mir jetzt willst ich Brau
wieder ein Podcast ich brauchst du
Therapie ach so was ich sagen wollte
dieser Teig ist jetzt fertig der ist
ziemlich klebrig wenn das der Fall ist
hab ihr alles richtig gemacht genao muss
er sein und jetzt bitte für mindestens
30 Stunden gerne auch 30
Stunden für 30 Minuten gerne auch 45 in
den Kühlschrank geben ja genau die
Füllung ist ja auch noch im Tiefkühler
das heißt gleich holen wir alles raus
und dann wird es nur noch
zusammengestellt und dann gebacken man
merkt glaube ich wenn ich mit die Filme
ja das stimmt richtig dann ja das ist so
dieses kennst du das wenn so beste
Freunde so in der Klasse sind so ist das
bei uns okay Leute 30 Stunden einfach
Kühen okay wir sehen uns dann in zwei
Tagen oder so so jetzt können wir
weitermachen alles ist schön gekühlt den
Teig steche ich mir ab mit meinem
teigptionierer damit ich auch immer
gleich viel Teig habe und sie
gleichmäßig
durchwerden Bo das ist aber krass das
Produkt ist krass das sieht wirklich süß
aus oder ja das ist echt krass teigier
ist echt krass glaub mir also Leute müss
kaufen der ist echt krass ich habe jetzt
hier auch noch eine Schüssel weiß nicht
ob ihr das sehen könnt aber eine
Schüssel mit einem bisschen Wasser und
es hilft wirklich sich die Hände immer
so ein bisschen zu befeuchten und jetzt
drücke ich hier so eine kleine Molde
rein und dann kommt unser
gefrorenes unser gefrorener Cheesecake
unsere gefrorene Cheesecake Füllung oh
ich kann nicht reden das kommt jetzt
rein genau und das ist jetzt die Füllung
und deswegen mussten wir das einmal tief
kühlen damit wir das überhaupt so
bewegen können damit du bist voll
schlau e ma Leute Jahren so aber egal du
bist schlau das ist jetzt nichts
weltbewegendes aber es ist cool ist eine
coole Art und Weise machen die Hände
wieder nass so und jetzt könnt ihr da
immer so sechs auf einem Blech
platzieren und nicht mehr weil sonst
gehen die ineinander und hab so ein
riesen Cookie ich habe jetzt hier unten
drunter auch mein Lochblech das ist mega
Game changer wenn ihr im Winter generell
halt mehr Plätzchen backt und aber so
riesiko so ein riesen Cookie wir haben
schon mal riesenroisson gegessen ne ja
riesen croisson haben wir jetzt in
London gegessen das haben wir aber auch
danach verteilt der weren das durch acht
geteilt glaube ich ich ma das jetzt
erstmal so weiter Ofen ist vorgeheizt
auf 180° Ober und Unterhitze und dann
verrate euch gleich die Backzeit aber
sie brauchen vermutlich so ca 10 bis 12
maximal 13
[Musik]
Minuten ja hallöchen ja hallöchen gibt
lecker Cookies lecker Cookies GI Monster
wi unterwegs hier also für euch noch als
Hinweis nach dem backen könnt ihr sie
auf jeden Fall noch 10 Minuten auf dem
Blech lassen denn sie backen von unten
dann noch mal so ein bisschen nach und
dann werden sie perfekt anfangs können
die sie nicht abheben also abheben
abmachen oder hochheben ohne dass sie
zerbrechen aber sobald Sie dann nur noch
lauwarm sind oder Erkalten könnt ihr sie
in die Hand nehmen das dazu als Hinweis
danke 10 Jahre später wichtig witig aber
ich fin cool dass wir schon aufgemacht
haben aber noch nicht gegessen haben ja
ich mache so noch mal ne nimmst du nicht
nim die erste Fuhre oder zweite Fuhre
jetzt das ist egal beide fuhren
schmecken lecker ja ich weiß aber ich
will so ich will ich will die zweite
Fuhre die lauwarme Fuhre ja hier das ist
die zwe das ist der zweite F ich neh den
offenen ich bin nachhaltig ich
verschwende NS wir verteilen noch in der
Crew weißt du doch scheiß auf die Hamsa
Spaß Spaß Spaß Spaß scheiß auf die je
nachdem wie lecker das ist ne sage ich
also okay wir
[Musik]
probieren
so
geil oh mein Gott es schmeckt so geil
ich liebe sowas ich liebe SAS gut K soll
ich mal sagen wo ich Kiki motiviert habe
du machst einen youtubeekanal soll ich
mal sagen das war als du mal so ein
Muffin gemacht hast Boston cream gemacht
Cupcake hast gemachtast gelieb das war
so ein gefüllter Muffin Boston cream
Kiki das ist so lecker das müssen wir
mal verfilmen das musst weiß ich gar
nicht aber du musst du das musst du mal
Teilen im Internet und so hab angefang
stimmt du hast immer gesagt dieser
Boston cream Cupcake den habe ich
gemacht und dann warst du immer auf der
Arbeit und bist dann rumgefahren und so
weiter im Sprinter und dann hast du das
mal gegessen unterwegs nicht so wie
quatschen Essen ich habe schon meins
weggeatmet das schmeckt so lecker es ist
einfach ein American Schoko Cookie wie
bei Subway hör auf meine Worte während
du probierst za Cookie komplett umhüllt
und in drin dieser cream cheesekern
cheern der ist Gang du musst nicht der
ist einfach so hi ich bin da ist Wied
gegang bin wieder weg tschüss so richtig
es zergeht im Mund es schmeckt total
lecker das schmeckt auch so ich finde
auch so amerikanisch ja also ich war in
New York ja da gab auch Cookies und in
Deutschland kriegst du sowas niemals
niemals ne in Deutschland finde ich
kriegst du SAS echt nicht oder hab den
Geheimtip sind ja auch mal unterwegs in
Großstädten kan man gute Cookies her
bekommen ich bralich beißen das ist der
Hammer also für Leute die keine Zähne
haben oder nicht essen können geht auch
schmeckt echt gut übrigens unser Podcast
ist online und zwar der Tuesday Talk und
wenn ihr wenn euch das nicht genug
Gequatsche war aber da ist du hast was
egal für mehr auf Youtube auf jeden Fall
schaltet ein zu unserem Podcast Tuesday
Talk jeden Dienstag da geht's um alles
mögliche und hör einfach rein ich will
gar nicht zu viel verraten Leute egal
wie aussieht das schmeckt ich sag ganz
ehrlich soll ich Punkte vergeben
unbedingt 100 von 10 Cookie Punkten was
das ist der leckerste ohne Spaß auch
ohne die Füllung der Kook schon so
lecker also nicht dass ich geschockt bin
ich weiß ja dass es schmeckt aber du
bist so kritis dein Rezept ist heftig
danke schön du hast auch mal Cookies
verkackt sag ich ganz ehrlich so also
jetzt nicht auf Youtube aber so privat W
sag ich ma jetzt Cookies mal ja man
experimentti da war ab und zu mal
vielleicht bisschen zu hart oder so aber
das war jetzt ganz selten der Fall aber
das ne e heftig das Rezept ist heftig
Leute es kommen nur die besten me
Rezepte auf Youtube schaffen gar nicht
runtergefallen ist heftig also geile
geile Konsistenz fudi heftig hoch 10 110
Punkte 100 Punkte fü mich geschmeichelt
also macht es unbedingt nach wie gesagt
die genauen Mengenangaben immer bei mir
in der Infobox und ansonsten freue ich
mich über Kommentare von Euch lasass uns
miteinander schreiben was wollt ihr
jetzt nächstes sehen habt ihr
Herzenswunsch oder so schreibt einfach
in die Kommentare ich habe
Schmetterlinge im Bauch oh so Cookie
Schmetterlinge oh das ist sü Hammer
lecker also wenn ihr echt jemanden
beeindrucken möchtet ohne Witz macht's
nach ohne Witz ehrlich Tag guck mal ich
habe mein Stress vergessen ich habe
einfach vergessen wie viel ich heute
noch zu tun habe glüshone hammer hammer
und immer noch schei die Cre alle na
Spaß wir machenlich gut dass die Crew
dein Humor versteht die sind alle so
lieb ganz kurz
auch das mit und ich werde eine zeigen
wie wir es verteilen werden
okay bring pa Mitarbeiter cies mit die
se nicht so schön aus
aber aber die schmecken
dankeönsonstsonst
bis zum nächsten Mal
[Musik]
tschüss fre den ich bin gierig weißt du
ja eigentlich auch big so die Hälfte
gehört jetzt aber noch mir ne mus nicht
wissen dass ichig bin weißt du nein muss
keiner die kam läuft alles gut ja die
ist ja eh schon aus von daher wir könen
uns jetzt einfach zusammen lass mal ein
filmmachen du